[Music]
we concluded the previous video with an
introduction to the concept of
antigen-antibody interaction let's have
a look at this concept in detail in this
video any idea how this interaction
takes place the answer lies in the
structure of the particular antibody
antibodies also known as immunoglobulins
are denoted with the abbreviation IG
they are Y shaped protein molecules
which are made up of different peptide
chains here we have a complete
representative structure of a typical
antibody this structure of antibody is
basically studied by dividing it into
two parts the constant region and the
variable region formed by these peptide
chains as the name suggests the constant
region means the peptide chains remain
the same in all antibodies on the other
hand the variable regions will have
peptide chains that can get altered as
per the requirement and what will this
requirement be that's right the
requirement will be the shape of this
site depending on the structure of the
antigen needless to say the antigen
binding site will be present in this
variable region there are many detailed
paths and structures present within
these variable and constant regions but
we will keep them reserved for the
higher grades for now all we need to
know is that all these paths together
constitute a complete antibody in us
humans to be precise we have different
types of antibodies these include IgM
IgG IgA IgG and IgA for now let's just
know their names and let's understand
how any type of antibody interacts with
any antigen that is designed to destroy
antigens as we know are the molecules
which are capable of triggering an
immune response upon
entering the body so when an antigen
enters the body the immune cells secrete
antibodies specific to the antigen that
means if this is the antigen then this
antibody with the binding site matching
its structure will be produced and once
the antibody encounters the specific
antigens it will quickly bind to it
somewhat like this this is the antigen
antibody interaction that we've been
talking about so far and such
interactions give rise to a cascade of
reactions which ultimately trigger the
immune response so imagine this is a
pathogen with these antigens at its
surface on encountering this one the
immune cells will make antibodies
specific to these antigens and thus an
interaction somewhat like this
will take place and as a result the
immune system will get further activated
this step may be extremely critical when
it comes to the fighting of the
infections in the body but how do we
understand it practically there are
several wet tests performed in the
laboratories that give us a glimpse of
such beautiful reactions
iliza test for example is one such
beautiful red test which is based on the
principle of antigen antibody
interactions let's see what this test is
all about ELISA which stands for enzyme
linked immunosorbent assay is a test in
biochemistry that helps in the assay of
a liquid sample to qualitatively and
quantitatively measure the particular
component present in it the principle is
quite simple
it's just the interaction of antigens
with antibodies ELISA is usually carried
out in a 96-well plate which looks
somewhat like this the bottom of this
plate will be coated with a known
antigen first then a sample containing
the antibodies is added to this but
there is a small twist here the
antibodies are linked with specific
enzymes these specific enzyme linked
antibodies will
to the antigen and what will happen
there on adding the substrate at the end
the enzymes linked to the antibodies
will bind to it and does show a change
in color the intensity of color change
helps detect the amount of the analyte
we're looking for this is just one type
of iliza which is known as direct ELISA
but we will restrict ourselves to this
much as we will now deviate towards the
concept of immunity
now that we've glanced over a few more
useful concepts related to immunity
let's understand its types in general
immunity in every human is divided
mainly into two broad categories one is
called the innate immunity and the
second is called acquired immunity
innate as the name suggests is a
nonspecific immunity present in an
individual right since the time of birth
on the other hand acquired immunity is
the one which is gained over a period of
time all which is developed during an
entire lifetime as and when we encounter
the pathogenic invasions this type is
highly specific in nature let's get into
the details of each type in the upcoming
videos till then do subscribe to our
channel for more cool videos on such
interesting topics
[Music]
you